the information in our genes is encoded
by an alphabet of four molecules called
nucleotides and there it's it's a simple
alphabet which the order in which the
letters are arranged encode all the
functions of a cell the first time that
that order was determined it cost a huge
amount of money and took a long time to
do years now it can be done in a day for
less than a thousand dollars
we call this complete genome sequencing
the genome is a term that simply refers
to the entire genetic information
contained in an in a cell right now most
advanced cancer centers will either us
determine the complete sequence of that
alphabet in the in the genome of
patients cancer cell you compare that to
the genome from their normal cells and
you can spot any genetic malformation
that gives rise to a malfunction so you
get a readout of potential targets for
therapeutics this is a work in progress
and the biggest impediment to a
completion of the project is data
analysis the data are accumulating more
rapidly than the bioinformatics can
decipher it
you